you'll like my last video so much thank
you I appreciate that
so let me tell you some more let me tell
you about my childhood let me tell you
about how I grew up where I came from
what I did before I I did YouTube well I
played tibia best [ __ ] game and boy
do I have some stories there are some
things I didn't say in my last video
because I just thought it was it was too
much too much to share you're just gonna
judge me completely for the rest of my
life so I wanted to tell you about the
worst thing I've ever done to someone
which was through this game tibia
because this game you could [ __ ] around
with it was like it's like an MMO with
no restrictions not like nowadays you
play I don't know League and you get
banned for toxic behavior why don't you
grow some balls how about that what is
gonna happen to our future generation
with these [ __ ] ass games
all right tibia you can do whatever the
[ __ ] you want all right the only ways
you could get banned if you were
cheating actually if you were caught
cheating or if you kill too many people
at once okay which was really [ __ ]
cool by the way cuz there was this one
spell called ultimate explosion and if
you really got really pissed you hit
that button the whole screen [ __ ]
explode everyone dies and you get into
the ban and you're like Bert sunglasses
just comes down and you're like [ __ ]
yeah then you cry because you got banned
but whatever see if it's the kind of
game that doesn't explain [ __ ] to you
but somehow people managed by just fine
okay we don't need hand-holding when you
start playing you start off in rooks
Guard which is this Ruby island what
it's called and you start killing rats
if you know what you're doing it
shouldn't take more than a couple hours
to get out of rook guard because he
wants to get to level eight you get to
talk to the Oracle and you get to decide
what class you want to be and you get to
the mainland where most of the action is
you know you don't want to stay in
regard you want to get the [ __ ] out as
soon as possible now it should only take
you a few hours to get out of rook card
for me the very first time it took three
[ __ ] weeks the game doesn't explain
[ __ ] okay it's so [ __ ] confusing you
start killing rats with your fists and
you're like I don't I don't think this
is it you get trapped by [ __ ] rats in
this [ __ ] cage and you're like god
dammit this is so humiliating
and then when you die in the game you
lose a level so it just it just brings
in even more at [ __ ] time okay and
there were holes there were these
[ __ ] holes in the games where you go
on you go down to find creatures or
whatever now everyone just wants to get
the [ __ ] out of rutgard as soon as
possible you really just fight for
finding the spawns okay the monsters you
want to kill as many as possible you
don't want other people to get the
experience so you go down these [ __ ]
holes and there's always a ladder so you
can get back up well if you go a little
too far or in the wrong [ __ ] hole
there's no ladder and you're like what
the hell what do i do how am I supposed
to get up and you start yelling cuz you
can yell in the game like help I'm stuck
there's no audio in the game but if you
hit this button you might it might show
a text for someone who's nearby outside
a screen now people would see it and
they would come down and they're like
well [ __ ] now we're both stuck down here
so I would tell my friend to start a new
character by a rope you needed a rope
for some [ __ ] reason by this very
specific guy for 50 gold which was a lot
of money so your friend had to get the
rope find the specific spot that you
were in and rope you up that's how you
got out now when we discovered this
we're like well
clearly 5050 goal that's a lot of money
I think we can make some money back on
this so we would we would trick people
to go down the same hall and then we
would go down with them and they would
be like [ __ ] I can't get up can you help
me and then I will just be like blip
blip blip blip going up and down like oh
oh there's a problem here oh I would
love to help you but you know ropes
ropes are expensive they're like okay 50
G if you rope me up I'm like okay I will
accept your money and your helmet
they're like no no I'm not gonna pay you
it's 50 G okay I know the rope and I'm
like wow it's either that or you're
gonna be [ __ ] stuck here and now you
know what I want your armor to I know
you have one oh it's so funny so we
would name we would just keep tricking
people to go in now this isn't that bad
it was just a fun thing to do fun thing
I don't many things you can do in the
game to [ __ ] people over there was a lot
of stuff you can do to [ __ ] around with
people in tibia for example if you
wanted to trade an item with someone
let's say a giant sword that's a really
expensive item in the game I don't
remember maybe like 25k well what's
funny about the giant sword it's it
looks very similar she were two-handed
sword
wishes it morphed [ __ ] all right so what
we would do is do you find someone that
wants to buy a giant sword and you would
trade them the giant sword and they
would trade in the gold and right before
you click accept you can sell and then
you ripe oops sorry
trade me again and then you trade in but
this time the two-handed sword and you
click okay they click okay without
looking because they look so similar and
bam you got yourself 25k and you pissed
someone up in the process that was the
thing about tibia if you were higher
level than someone they were your [ __ ]
but anyone higher level than you you
were their [ __ ] but there was also the
constant fear and terror and paranoia
that you would [ __ ] with someone lower
level that had a friend because everyone
had a [ __ ] high level friend okay and
it was the worst thing but there was one
thing that happened
that was probably too far probably we
took it a little little too far let me
tell you what it is okay it's the worst
thing I've ever done to someone okay
here we go
since tbo was so popular in Sweden where
I grew up people would ride on like eBay
the Swedish eBay who buy specific items
for him for real money so I found
someone that was interested in buying an
item that I had and I thought well
that's that's kind of funny I'll accept
that trade hey I'll take real money so I
would tell him to meet me up at a net
cafe because we lived in the same city
and to make this trade but the thing was
the thing was that we had installed a
key lock on the computer which basically
mean we could get his password and login
so we would meet him up and the guy was
[ __ ] old like he was way older than
me he was probably 18 and I'm like what
Jesus Christ there's no way I can go
through with this it's gonna [ __ ]
kill me I just went through with the
trade because I didn't want to [ __ ]
die so I got my money he got his item
and then we were off our merry way but
then I realized I still had his log it
was right you know it was right there it
was it would be like they would it would
be theft not to take it okay I log in
and I'd send my item back so basically
this is like that pretty much I assume
this is like robbery
I took my atom bag but the thing was
like my friends were with me we didn't
just take back our ID we took all his
side and you think I might be done okay
you mean you may think I crippled this
guy enough and if you're watching the
guy that we did this to I am sorry okay
I don't know what was wrong with me but
we thought it would be funny to kill his
character so he would go back to rook
guard the newbie level but we killed him
an ungodly amount of times until he got
to level 8 and he was sent back to rook
guard the newbie island with no islands
and no dignity
it's like if you wanted to kill someone
you wouldn't just kill them you would
first you would cut off their limbs and
cut off their balls and send them into
the [ __ ] ocean that's been pretty
much what we did to this guy's character
I can't even imagine just having this
character that you worked so hard on and
then logging in one day and you're back
in newbie island you know I still got
nightmares okay I realize this is a
pretty terrible thing to do and I I
apologize okay if you're watching I am
sorry but it was really funny at the
time
everyone was pretty much an [ __ ] for
playing this game I mean there were some
there were some white knights quite
literally as well but I I think anyone
who had fun with this game what was an
[ __ ] in this game so yeah that's some
more tibia stories for you as the game
that I grew up with in my childhood I
was really entertained by reading what
you guys childhood games were as well so
leave a comment and liver like if you
want more stories like these I really
enjoyed making them and as always stay
awesome breasts please don't judge me
too much okay listen I was young I
didn't know any better
you
[Music]